foreign
with my husband constantly he's recently
been like hey you know can you chill and
stop [ __ ] me around I don't know how
this has absolutely zero to do with him
none
zero
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
delone his show greatest mental health
and marriage and parenting podcast ever
so glad that you're with us if you want
to be on this show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask fill out the form it will go to
Kelly and Jenna and they will judge you
and your question and see if it gets on
the internet show I'm so glad you're
here hey before you do anything else
if you're watching this on YouTube
please hit subscribe it helps get this
out to everybody else like it's it's not
buying me a house or a car or anything
it's a way you can support this show and
the conversations we're having
um without without literally spending a
penny and it'd be a gift and if you're
listening to this on podcast please go
do a five-star review
um if you have to do a one star review
just find some random podcast and tank
it but if you're gonna do it one I'm
just kidding don't do that don't be mean
um as your mom said if you do anything I
say don't say anything at all
if your mom didn't say that and she was
like no we burned the little ones to the
ground don't do that either don't do
that either and I I guess if your mom
talked like that she probably smoked a
lot too
oh boy we're not even on the train yet
and it's already off the rails let's go
to Elena oh and Oklahoma Okay Oklahoma
I'm gonna smile Elena in Oklahoma and
Tulsa what's up
hey this is really surreal it is super
surreal for me but this is crazy good to
have you yeah like a month ago listening
to you live for the first time with the
every dollar convention now here I am
pretty crazy oh yeah you were you in
Oklahoma
uh we no we were in Dallas we drove down
there for the to be there on that
Saturday oh that's super fun that was a
fun day huh yeah it was pretty awesome
pretty awesome so that's very cool so
what's up how can I help
all right so I feel like it kind of
boils down to
um I feel like I just lose my mind with
my husband constantly I've been here up
in here yelling always like controlling
telling him what to do nagging and he's
recently been like hey you know can you
chill and stop bossing me around I
I can't figure it out it's like every
time uh you know something comes up like
can you do the dishes can you do like
vacuum the floors I just go ballistic
wow why what does that get you it gets
you something what does it get you
a feeling of control I don't know
I guess that's kind of it's um
I guess we whenever we first got married
we really struggled he kind of didn't
know like how to help around the house
so I did a lot of it did a lot of uptake
and uh in the beginning I really did
have to kind of encourage and tell them
what to do because his response was I
just can't see it like I don't know when
the things are dirty I don't see the
carpet and you see vacuumed I don't
think of like mopping the kitchen floor
okay and you know a lot has changed in
the past like year and a half but um I
still can't like relinquish that he'll
get it done maybe not this instant
like he'll do it
this has absolutely zero to do with him
no zero
so here's my question for you you ready
and you're not gonna like it that's okay
it's okay we're friends
um
and you feel free to be like eh you're
an idiot you're wrong but I don't think
I am okay okay
when you were a young little girl
you either grew up in a system where you
had no control at all
or it was a super chaotic environment
or the way you found control or kept dad
from screaming or kept mom from getting
off the rails or whatever was order
tell me I'm wrong this soon am I right
or wrong
yeah I know uh so I come from
um a lot of trauma in my childhood some
of it was related to my parents as long
as it was sexual abuse when I was really
young
um but I grew up in a lot of like
screaming and yelling from Dad and I
guess it was really confusing yeah and
now here I am doing the same thing and I
just can't
get rid of it and then um hold on hold
on hold on hold on
your dad's screaming and yelling
was because he had a little boy
that was still trying to protect him
and I'm not giving him a pass okay at
all
your response to your husband is that of
a kid
and that tells me you have a child who's
still trying to keep you safe
because somebody had to keep you safe
because the adults in your life sure as
hell weren't doing it
in fact they were the ones hurting you
and that little girl learned some
techniques and tricks
to keep on some sort of path because
nobody was helping her along
point you've got to make peace with that
little girl
and you've got to let her stop fighting
all your battles you gotta let her know
I'm all right now
I'm an adult now
so is that the kind of thing I can you
know go to my parents for and like maybe
share with him no they cashed out they
cashed out
they cashed out
yeah this conversation this starts with
you right writing your number one if
you've never talked to somebody about
your childhood sexual abuse you need to
do that
so we did we went to court all that
Shenanigans no yeah but that's you're a
tool at that point
you were somebody else's you were an
attorney's tool you're a uh cause for
your parents
did you go talk to a counselor
do you talk to a play therapist
yeah I did but it's it's been a while
and I hated it every single time do you
have little kids
no we're expecting I'm uh pregnant with
our first so I'll be here in May so when
was uh when did your sexual abuse start
um when I was eight or six sorry you
really don't remember a whole lot
is 11. okay so uh what are you having a
boy or girl
we don't know yet we don't know until
December waiting for the anatomy scan so
that's made me really anxious the
anatomy scan you couldn't have said that
grosser the anatomy
I have to say it to myself because I
keep wanting to go buy like the blood
prick test and find out like tomorrow
we're like we're AI children
um
so there's a part of your body that
knows you're bringing a kid in the kid's
not going to be safe
yeah okay I already feel kind of convert
everyone who they're with your body
has been out of control your whole life
and you've tried to make peace with that
through order
through control
through Straight A's my guess you
probably made great grades through you
are a on time at work and you are so
pissed off when people are late like me
who comes just strolling in
and you just solve things because I'm
gonna I'm gonna you're gonna take all
the variability out of every single
interaction relational or otherwise
because that's how you're gonna stay
safe
and that is how you're gonna squash joy
laughter sleep
rambunctious great connected sex
because of this constricted hold on
everything and if you let go of this if
you feel like you let go
use control everything and this little
girl has worked too hard to lose control
and then when your ding dong husband who
loves you like crazy right
yeah comes Walton through and just plops
down and grabs a video game controller
and doesn't even see the pile of
underwear didn't he didn't see it
the only emotion you have is nine years
old
and it comes out in Rage
or nagging you know who nags my kid
young kids can I have a snack can I have
ice cream why can't I have it why the
dog's not walking
and now you're an adult does that make
sense
yeah okay so here's what I want you to
do number one I want you to get back in
touch with the counselor okay okay let
them know that you are had systemic like
over three four five six years worth of
childhood sexual abuse
ended up in a court hearing all this
mess you had a raged out angry father
and God knows about your mom and dad and
his relationship and all that kind of
stuff
but let your counselor know you're about
to have a baby
and a lot of things are starting to
resurface
okay that's number one
you will feel a heightened sense of
relief and a heightened sense of anxiety
when you make that appointment
okay just expect that
you're going to go the first meeting and
you're going to hate it you're not going
to feel good about it because what
you're doing is you're relinquishing the
control you've held so tightly for so
long and I want you to feel that you
hate it and go anyway
okay that's the hardest part yes you are
practicing letting go of the steering
wheel and finding out the car is not
going to crash
okay that's what we're practicing here
the second thing is I want you to write
that nine-year-old girl a letter
nine-year-old Elena gets a letter
okay that says Dear Elena I'm so sorry
this was never your job
to defend yourself against dad
to wonder why Mom wasn't showing up for
you
why somebody sexually abused you and why
I was allowed to go on when everybody
kind of knew something was up
and I want you to write 14 year old
Elena a letter
because 14 15 16 17 18 year old Elena
went through hell didn't she
pretty much
she needs to be off the hook too
and what we're going to do is we're
going to systematically
teach our body that if we let our hands
off the wheel the whole thing doesn't
crash
we're going to systematically teach our
body that the little girl who's been
protecting us for all these years can
finally go play
which is what she should have been able
to do so many years ago
and then here's the third thing
when you yell
you stop yourself stop
just stop and let your husband know in a
moment when y'all aren't mad at each
other
or you're not mad at him
I am going to consciously stop yelling
I'm gonna quit
because I'm going to be a mom that
doesn't yell
I'm gonna be a mom that doesn't yell
I'm gonna be a wife that doesn't nag
and so what that means is you're going
to have to learn how to say your needs
out loud in Crystal clearness like
crystal clearness that's not even a word
and very very clear in HD okay
and instead of saying like
um
hey you need to clean the bathroom you
need to clean the garage you need it
instead of that
it's a very calm and quiet
when I come home and you're sitting on
the couch playing video games and the
laundry's not done
I feel in my body
you're telling me through your behavior
because behavior is a language you're
telling me I don't care about her
yeah I don't love her
not enough to vacuum
that makes you feel really crazy like it
doesn't look like a mind game it does
but listen it's a game that only you're
playing he doesn't even know a game he
doesn't know
and you can go down a rabbit hole if his
mommy didn't train him and all that
that's a waste of time
because here because we're here now
and he deserves the right for you to be
very clear about what you need not about
how he's failing and what a loser he is
and how he doesn't even that's not what
he needs because his defense mechanisms
go up when he goes under attack they
should he needs to hear the best way to
love his wife
and when he doesn't here's how that
feels here's what it does to your body
and what you're going to have to do is
feel for the first time in a long time
something other than
uh rage anger
disappointment frustration
yeah is that fair
yeah and then I I kind of I had another
thing I wanted to ask you about too
because that's that covered a lot again
really surprised you picked up like one
sentence
um when we first got married he was
military and he was a pretty severe
alcoholic and so I dealt with a lot of
like uh you know good language being
shoved around and pushed aside and like
it was a constant fight of like can you
please stop drinking and then uh it's
been almost a year since he stopped
because he didn't show up on one one
night home and so I pretty much told him
it's either like me or your beard and I
just can't let go of of that version of
him it's like all the time I see him and
I just feel like he's that's still there
and I'm just kind of like waiting
for it to come back and waiting for him
to you know call me names or like get
really drunk one day and just go off the
walls and
you know he reassures me that's not
gonna happen but I just
it almost becomes it hey your body's
just do it your body's working great
is taking care of you exactly as it
should
because your dad shouldn't have yelled
and screamed too
yeah and your mom should have shown up
for you
and your body recognizes when people
show up and say they love Elena that's
when the hurt starts
and so you got right back in you married
your unfinished business and you were
gonna fix another man and that guy was
angry and dealing with his own PTSD
stuff and he was drinking and he was
abusive
and your brain put a GPS pin in him too
poof not safe
but since this is what we deserve and we
have a plan for this it's called control
we'll just go down that road right
because your body never even occurred to
you that you're worth more than this
because you've never ex you can talk
about peace and oh my gosh well look at
that guy in The Bachelor he seemed so
sweet you've never felt that
yeah right not really so has he quit
drinking
yeah yeah it's been almost a year when's
the last time you put his hands on you
over a year ago okay
have you all gone to counseling to
figure out how to build a new
relationship on the back of that
no yeah I've brought it up a lot of
times
you have to
yeah tell them how do I get him to go
tell him you're interested in building
something new
yeah
an entirely new marriage and that is
different than we need to go so I can
quit getting mad at you for how you used
to drink and hit me like that's you see
what I'm saying he's gonna lock up
mm-hmm the same as if he came to you and
said I we need to go to counseling
because you quit nagging me and whatever
and then boom you're Off to the Races
yeah we have both everyone's got defense
mechanisms built in for that moment
when the relationship gets threatened
boom we have our own responses
based on genetics life experience any
whatever's worked in the past
so it's not about him
it's about you
honey I want to be the wife that my dad
didn't have
and I want to love you recklessly and
I've got to learn to trust you again
because you hit me
yeah I've got to learn to love you again
because you're a scary alcoholic and I
trust that you're different but I've got
to learn some new skills I'm asking you
to come to a marriage counselor with me
and spend some time learning some new
skills with me
and if he looks at you and says no
that's stupid
your relationship has much bigger issues
and then what what if that is what he
says that's like I just
I don't know I just get really scared
that uh here's the deal man
we avoid the or what conversation all of
us do
yeah I'm not gonna tell my boss I can't
keep working 90 hour weeks or my wife's
Gonna Leave Me
or he might so we say nothing and she
leaves
I'm not going to tell my husband who's
abusive that if he hits me one more time
because because then what and so we just
say nothing
foreign
I need you to hear me Elena I need you
to hear me so clear
you have to have boundaries that you
draw
and when you draw boundaries that has to
come with a or what sentence and or what
on the back end
you can't tell these jokes around my
kids anymore grandparents
or my kids will not be around you
I will make sure of that
you cannot hit me again or I will leave
and I'll be devastated and I will be
alone but I won't be getting hit
and you will sit down and say I need us
to build a new marriage and I want to
build something from scratch that
neither of us have ever seen before
and if he looks at you and says Ah I'm
good
that would be a devastating
shh and that's when you and your
counselor can have worked out the or
what and it doesn't have to be I'm
leaving it can be okay I'm gonna work on
new things I'm going to commit to not
yelling I'm going to commit to I'm going
to commit to
because at the end of the day the only
person you can control is you your
thoughts and your actions and that's it
that's it
the or what is hard the OverWatch is
scary but that comes with every boundary
and probably for the first time in your
life you're
gonna peel back a lot of layers of
protection and a lot of layers of false
control and a lot of layers of a little
kid protecting you and you're gonna have
to ask yourself the scariest question
possible what am I gonna do next
hang on the line Elaine I'm going to
send you on your pass change your future
to be my gift to you and check it out
and I want you to read it I want you to
let me know how that goes
I'm proud of you for getting to this
moment
and I need you to hear me say clearly
you're worth going to sleep
you're just laughing from your guts
you're worth a great marriage
do you decide this guy's worth
um forgiving and letting him heal y'all
are worth building something new
together
and all of it starts today
we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
it is time for I was gonna say
everybody's favorite segment or nobody's
favorite segment the new segment called
facts are your friends
look at this cool little thing over here
that looks awesome way to go
who made that backdrop
one of the Zeroes
it's been a while so we've had it
amazing awesome back to your friends all
right
so
I'm kind of breaking my own rule here
and here's what it is
I don't usually like to read old things
unless they're old nerd articles
and I don't like to
I don't like click baity stuff and I
don't like to go on that rabbit hole
because I've learned from my journalist
friends that a lot of things they write
they don't even believe in them they
because their job isn't to write
articles that are believable their their
job is to get clicks and so they make
things the most clickbaity but enough of
you sent me this article and I guess
it's like an editorial piece and it's
old it's a year old it's from it's
almost a year and a half June 16th 2021.
and I'm not even going to give the
author's name because I don't want to
give this author credence
the name of the article is called don't
play with your kids
seriously that's the name of the article
don't play with your kids seriously
[Music]
here's the way the article goes
my older son recently made a vending
machine out of a cardboard box my
daughter created clothing for her
Barbies out of paper and tape by the way
it's the New York Times
my baby went through the hall closet
describing the shoes in a babble that
was only one-eighth English
all three participate in a steampunk
inspired world of their own creation
yada yada
their games are going well the kids are
murmuring saying to one another pretend
we or what if we or the queen must be
assassinated lots of screaming meanwhile
I'm doing the crossword
the author goes on to say and this is
verbatim
I have three kids under 10 who don't
expect or even want to play with me it
took some practice but over time we've
all learned we're better off doing our
own thing the kids without stodgy
parental interference and my husband and
I unhooked from the assumption that we
have to play to be present
now
here's why I'm choosing a comment on
this and a facts of your friends segment
this is the kind of arrogant over
academization
and this is Two Guys a guy with two phds
I know academics
this is somebody who has thought
themselves into a pretzel
and has created an outcome academically
that they wanted
and has reverse engineered this
narrative that this makes some sort of
sense
in its insanity
it's Madness
and quite honest it's heartbreaking goes
on to say it wasn't always this way as a
toddler
um
my first child wasn't digging in the
trash or chewing on the couch cushions
he was rampaging through the house with
an imaginary weapon he never listened
because he was a toddler
I tried to run into traffic cause he's a
toddler it's what they do the constant
wrangling and vigilance was so
exhausting
you mean parenting
that my husband and I didn't have the
energy to play the way my son preferred
anything that involved full body contact
or pretend violence
instead I said no and stop all day long
you mean instead of putting down the
crossword puzzle and getting on all
fours and
making eye contact with your son and
touching him on the face and letting him
feel seen and heard
that just would have been too
inconvenient because you'd work on the
crossword puzzle
I was a terrible Playmate I felt guilty
and frustrated a tired mother who did
little Beyond obstructing
so you quit on him
you quit on him
he's just too hard it's too rambunctious
too energetic
but when I my son was about three I
realized his fictive worlds were vivid
enough to continue without me all he
needed at first was a listener
after a while he would head into his
bedroom alone to transform it into a
place that lived in his mind
this my friends is a trauma response
this is a child who is desperately
trying to make connection with the
adults in its life in his life
and whose adults are too busy with the
crossword puzzle or Instagram or their
show or work or their weight loss
program or their working out program or
whatever else they're focused on
and there comes a point
that a child will fold in on himself or
herself
head off alone
into a room
and their body will compress their
feelings
and will Channel them inside their own
mind
little by little my husband and I would
stretch the time our son could safely
play by himself it was freedom for all
of us
this is insanity yes young kids can
learn to play by themselves and it's
important that they develop autonomy and
all that that's fine
but the idea that you're taking a
three-year-old and teaching them to be
alone
this is the Cornerstone of selfishness
and Madness
it's Madness
when you have a kid you give up the
crossword puzzle
adults
when you have a kid that's rambunctious
you join in with them
you don't beat it out or neglect it out
of them
when you have a child who is quiet and
reserved
you dude I listened to 90s country on
the way to work sometimes do you think I
like it no I want to set my eardrums on
fire
but my son loves it and I'm making
connections with him
the other day we spent nine hours nine
agonizing hours in the woods hunting
you know what came out no things nothing
I would have given up and left and when
I said hey you want to go
no I did no it's good this is good for
us
so I sat with him hour after hour
because my presence
is a gift
do I like it no am I perfect that I'm
terrible at it I'm working on this all
the time
but I'm not partnering with my wife to
see how we can slowly reduce the amount
of time that our kids have access to us
so that they in turn have to figure out
a new life alone
look around we've created the loneliest
generation in human history with this
kind of nonsense
foreign
I can be critical I'm distracted by work
and life I have a bad temper and I don't
like to play especially pretend or
anything with dolls or figures or any
games that ask me to hide or wield a
Nerf gun gun my motto is moms don't play
the other context also applies I do not
play
I can't say my Approach is right for
everyone it's a right for No One
because when you have kids
foreign
here's here's the most important part
I know that it resonates for me in part
because of how I was raised I have no
memories of my parents playing with me
I can remember reading together and
they're swimming with me in the ocean
but they weren't involved in the fashion
shows I filmed with my sisters and they
didn't help me make my magazine kid
stuff either not once did they die at my
fictional restaurant
could this be why as an adult
your kids have a mom that doesn't play
or that you're critical and have a bad
temper you're distracted by work because
you have a little child inside
wondering what is so bad about my little
restaurant that my parents won't even
bother to come see me
what is it about me that's so bad that
my parents won't play
what is so awesome about that crossword
puzzle
that makes it more worthy of my mom and
dad's attention than me
and that makes for an exhausted bitter
critical angry adult
maybe you're the living result of your
relationship free childhood Maybe
that's not fair
but when I see this kind of gymnastic
nonsense it's academic gymnastics
really I don't want to be bothered by my
kids because they're annoying to me
kids are boring they're messy they're
loud they're rambunctious they run into
traffic or they just sit there and do
nothing they poop 111 times a day
they're annoying they're bothering me
so I'm going to
work backwards and create a narrative
that makes this all okay
oh they don't want to even play with me
they just want to sit in their own mind
in their room alone
it's nonsense
parents
do the exact opposite of this article
play with your kids
invite your kids with you everywhere you
possibly can it's gonna take longer it's
going to be annoying there's going to be
certain conversations you can't have
because your kid's sitting right there
and if you really have to have a deep
hard private conversation cool go have
adult time that's awesome that's
important
my wife and I do couples dates and we
all go out to restaurants no kids it's
great but if I'm going to help a buddy
of mine fix a thing my kid comes with me
if I'm going hunting with a buddy my kid
comes with me
if I need to go get the car worked on my
kids come with me because I need them to
see how the world works and how their
dad interacts with adults and how their
mom interacts with
play with your kids and there's times
that get on all fours and I'm sitting at
a restaurant and my daughter I don't
understand what we're eating I don't
understand what we're doing I think
there's wolves and Dragons running
around I don't know what's happening but
I'm there
and I'm not a great parent
but I understand the neurodevelopmental
importance of this the socio psychosa
the psychosocial development I'm just
getting so frustrated listen moms and
dads
playing with your kids
be present with your kids
let your kids not just see but feel how
valuable they truly are
teach them about relationship teach them
about connection teach them about
relationships that are more important
and the crossword puzzle and if you find
yourself bitter or critical
or angry or someone a dad who just
doesn't play
be an adult
and work on those things
do what you can to heal be less critical
be more supportive
you don't know how to play learn how to
play
parents
play with your kids
seriously
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement an MLs ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back and I still got
hemorrhoids from that last
article cheese that we use
not gonna get any cards and letters on
that one it's all good all right let's
go to Louisville Kentucky and talk to
Kyle what's up Kyle
hey John how's it going partying man
what are you up to
oh sitting in the parking lot
one of those days huh oh always what's
up um so I have a relationship question
um been in a relationship with my
girlfriend for
about two years
um I previously gotten to the point
where I thought we were going to get
married and purchased a ring instead of
playing to propose all that stuff and
then we moved in together
after my lease expired and uh after
living together for just a couple of
months I'd actually cancel my plan to
propose and just delayed it and now
we've been living together for about
seven months and I've actually returned
the ring for partially financial and
personal reasons
um and just feel like we're miles from
being ready to get married
um you've been like wanting to work on
improving our health and getting on a
budget and do the Ramsey plan and
improve ourselves just kind of in
general but she tends to like get on
board after we talk and then Fall Off
Track within a week or two
um and it's happened constantly
um currently I've kind of felt more like
her parent and her boyfriend due to the
issues with
you know the budgeting and the living
healthy but also just like chores and
managing like normal adult
responsibilities that we all have
um I'm kind of lost on how to manage a
situation and have kind of shut down and
just grinding and focusing on improving
myself now and have no idea where to go
so I'm kind of wondering if I'm at the
point where I need to move on with the
relationship
or just like leave and you know because
I don't know how it's gonna work when
you had kids and parenting and more
stress into life you know
yeah
I'm sorry because you're you're at a
scary juncture in your relationship and
this is It's a heavy moment right
yeah uh does she feel the same way
like she doesn't understand my
frustrations when
you know I I tell her I'm frustrated
with something and she thinks it's kind
of playful and again she might like you
know improve for a couple of weeks or
something that falls off the wagon just
kind of into the same run and then and
then I bring it up again and then she
kind of makes me feel guilty for
being I don't know she makes me feel
like I'm attacking her or something when
I'm
just trying to you know get her to put
her socks in the hamper
yeah I don't see a great future for this
relationship my brother and here's why
you think you're better than her
that you've you've arrived at some
certain plateaus that are superior to
her
and
you you said it you've me you've entered
into dad mode
and
you're playing house and so you're not
there's there's not there's not a
marital commitment here so you've left
yourself an out
and because you left yourself an out
you're continuing to lean more and more
towards that exit door
and so what I would suggest is you're
being cruel to yourself and to her right
now and here's what cruel is it's either
hanging on to a relationship dude that
you know you're going to end
I mean you just walked me through the
steps on how this thing is slowly
winding itself up
and you've been able to wrap your head
around like I'm being prudent I'm just
taking things slow I'm just oh hold on
I'm slowing back dude you sold the ring
man
right
there's there's that side of it the
other side of it is dude you need to
learn right now
whoever you marry
you can't make them do anything
you can't control them you can't change
them
the only person on planet Earth you can
control is you right
and
are you
damn near perfect with your health and
your budgeting and the way you spend
money and the way you take care of
yourself
no absolutely not and I mean are you
projecting your frustrations on your own
lack of discipline unto her
um maybe a little bit but I mean I'm
see like I when when I get on a plan to
do that kind of thing I can do it just
fine until
you know
until what until you quit
or get you know the way I kind of see it
more of the time is almost like sabotage
where it's like we'll talk and we'll be
like all right we're gonna eat healthy
we're gonna be on a diet and then she
goes grocery shopping and comes home
with ice cream cool man great but you
eat it
yep I do yep you do
y'all all get a great we're gonna work
out and then she doesn't work out that
first morning she didn't work out that
second morning and you don't work out
that third morning
well I've gotten to the point now that
I'm kind of doing it on my own without
her but now it just feels like
right I feel like I'm being a horrible
partner because I'm I'm like
I've I've tried to remind her and stuff
like that and if I just I don't know
if she feels great in her body
you've got to make peace with the fact
that you're not attracted to her
if she feels great with the way she
spends her money you've got to make
peace with the fact that she this may
not be the relationship for you right
now
more so than any of it you have to make
peace with the fact that you're not
following through the things you said
you were going to do either
regardless of the distractions
all right is that fair
yeah and I just
you know like I've been on my plan doing
it good for like almost two months now
and I just I feel like I've been a crap
partner because I haven't been able to
you know like I'm not taking her with me
and I'm I'm seeing myself improving no
no no no she's
choosing to not go with you
it's not you're not taking her with you
she's choosing to not go she's an adult
she gets to do that
all right
now if that is a relational deal breaker
for you and I'm not going to judge
whether it is or not that's fine
you have to be honest about that
right
is that fair
yeah I mean just like with health stuff
though I mean
you know I'm sure part of it's probably
physical attraction stuff but another
part of it is just being healthier to
have more time together and stuff like
that but I mean
I just I don't know behavior is a
language
she is opting out of those activities
with you
so you can either change your activities
here's a good example my wife won't go
running with me
we both get too competitive and then
both of us end up being just especially
me I end up being stupid about it she
will though go on a one to two hour walk
with me every Saturday morning
and we finally crossed that threshold
where the two our two kids can be at
home by themselves for a few hours and I
load up my ruck sack my backpack with
weights and I can get a good workout in
and go for a walk with my wife for a
couple hours so we I had to learn
something different she won't lift
weights with me she does it on her own I
do it on my own it's cool I made peace
with that
but we do do things together but it's
hiking it's different than I would have
chosen but they are great it's a great
compromise for both of us so you can
decide I will only go do CrossFit and
she has to come with me
she's telling you I'm not doing that
so you can say is there other things
you'd like to do would you go for a walk
with me every day would you go hiking
with me every couple times a week
you can do that and you have the
humility to change your workout programs
or do that on top of what you're doing
but all that goes back to you changing
you which is the only person you can
change and you can continue to invite
her out
but you probably haven't said is hey
when I invite you to go work out with me
there's Health components to that
there's the Attraction part of that all
that
but more so I like spending time with
you and I miss you
and when you say no to me I feel like
you're saying you don't want to spend
time with me
are there other ways we could spend time
together
that's vulnerability
right that's not luxury you see what I'm
saying
it's a totally different posture
when you leave socks on the floor
I feel like you're telling me
my time is not valuable you don't care
that's different than your gross pick up
your socks do we raise in a barn there's
a difference there right
right
and so instead of pointing out all the
things she's not doing
be a man enough
to be vulnerable enough
to say hey here's what I need
to be to have peace in my soul I need
things picked up and I'm willing to do
way more than my fair share but if
you'll just at least pick up your stuff
it's a gift to me
right that makes sense that's you
stating your needs not you being her dad
yeah and I don't I don't know that I've
gone about it that way no I mean most of
hey dude trust me I haven't either most
of us haven't
um here's my question my big question
for you okay are you gonna break up with
her or not
because you know
I don't know ah Kyle you know
I mean I sold the ring months ago and
it's been I mean like
Kyle Kyle Kyle are you gonna break up
with her because if you are do it you
what
I said I don't want to
what are you waiting for like I love her
as a person and
I love everything about her but it's
just like that doesn't mean that doesn't
mean it's the right person to marry and
you don't love everything about her
that's dishonest
yeah here
and here's my my super guess
I don't even know what a super guess is
you've been hoping she would read your
mind on some things for months and
months and months and she's not reading
your mind and you're not being clear
and as my boss Dave says to be unclear
is to be unkind
it's cruel to expect something of
somebody to want something of somebody
and not tell them
right and so I think it's fair I think
it's time to have a hard conversation
or a couple in some sort of retreat some
sort of what are we doing
does she know you sold the ring
no she didn't she didn't even know I
purchased it yeah I think it's time to
come clean because you're living a whole
life behind this thing
did y'all buy a house together
um no she purchased a house and then
after my lease expired I moved in okay
I think you need to have a very real
conversation with her
and it's going to be devastating it's
going to be heavy I bought a ring and
then we moved in together and I haven't
been the
husband that I wanted to be even though
we're not married
I'm asked you to read my mind and
haven't done a good job so here's how I
feel
or
I thought I was ready to get married and
I'm just not and it's in I need to move
out
or I'm going all all in I want to go
elope this weekend
and we're gonna build a marriage that is
so amazing and so incredible and so
honest with one another I'm gonna tell
you what I need I need you to hear me
what you need and we're going to build
from there is that fair
yeah because you're living halfway man
and I know how exhausting and anxious
that is
yeah it really is it's exhausting but
there's a there's a physical a
physiological toll of Secrets
[Music]
and it's time for you to tell the truth
are you in
yep
I know this is a hard conversation
uh
please write this down
write down what you're thinking what
you're feeling what your needs are
make it about you not about her much
less about her than about you I'll be
honest about the ring about all of it
come clean tell the truth
and from that Foundation
y'all can make decisions on the future
of a relationship she's worth that and
you are too my brother we'll be right
back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show the
other day I was at uh going to the gas
station and Kelly pulled in next to me
and it stunned me but she has an entire
car wrap of the group Brooks and Dunn
huge fan huge fan she hasn't gone with a
tattoo yet but she went with the like a
car wrap super strange like Brooks on
one side duns on the other and I was
like what is this about and I just saw
her in her car jam into this song sing
at the top of her Kelly lungs
it's a song that makes your heart beat a
little bit faster it's called The Boot
Scoot Boogie
and it goes like this
here in the country past the city limits
sign well there's a honky tonk near the
County Line This is the part when
Kelly's started just almost head banging
a little bit The Joint starts jumping
every night when the Sun goes down they
got Whiskey Women music and smoke it's
where all the cowboy folk goes this is
when our heart started beating so fast
they go to Boot Scoot Boogie
yeah heel toe doci doe come on baby
let's go Boot Scootin whoa Cadillac
Blackjack baby meet me out back Kelly
gross we're gonna Boogie oh get down
turn around go to town
the Boot Scootin Boogie
[Music]
that's all I'm gonna say about that I
love you guys stay in school don't do
drugs see you soon
[Music]